I want to remind this very smart room
that the number one advertiser on Google
during the five to seven golden years of
it being massively underpriced attention
was a company called Amazon when you
strike when you have the best hand you
win
you got your perspective I mean I don't
get that you know in 1996 my dad had a
liquor store in New Jersey
that's as traditional as you get yeah
that was 22 years ago and and I put my
dad's store on online and I did email
marketing and I did Google and I did
content and then a couple months after
YouTube came out I started YouTube show
in 2006 which is now 12 years ago I I I
have no respect or normally I deploy a
lot of empathy I struggled deploying
empathy I struggled deploying compassion
if you were a business operator in 2018
heading about I'm recording this in
October 2019 which is a majority people
gonna listen to this and you and your
excuses will I'm a pub or I make tomato
juice or I have three restaurants like a
digital is oxygen it's it's it's the
real world feel secondary yeah like to
not be a communicator content producer
part of the conversation
it's it's now it's gone from cute and
naive to grossly negligent you know and
I just think it's unacceptable to be a
business in 2019 in the same way that it
would be to pay people not minimum wage
like I literally believe it's grossly
unacceptable like to me it's like it's
like to quantify digital versus
traditional just marketing like really
you think sending direct mail print is a
better thing to do than advertising on
Instagram as a restaurant like like
really like really sit down with me
you're telling me right now that it's a
better deal
to spend all that money making a flier
and sending it directly out or running a
radio ad or buying a small little ad in
a newspaper like this is what you're
telling me it is 20 19 I felt bad in
2002 it was early the internet was new I
had compassion it was cute in 2007 it
was like hmm it was kind of like uh not
like hey annoying kind of like hmm but
still kind of in 2012 like you're not
smart in 2019 like yeah you deserve to
die look I want people to be healthy and
happy I just don't think that we should
demonize people that love their work and
we've gone the other way like like I
love working like like it like I'm sad
when I'm not working so shouldn't I work
like who's to tell me what time I should
spend with my like work-life balance
like I will never have the audacity to
tell somebody how the parent I will have
my points of view I will share them just
like others but nobody understood nobody
talked about quality yeah everybody's
talking about quantity I think that's
very nice that mom and dad are home at
5:00 p.m. but if they're both still
working on the phone are they actually
spending time with the kids like so you
know people need to be healthy and so
like if you're working yourself into
depression I think people don't
understand that most people have bad
work-life balance because they buy dumb
[ __ ] because they want to look cool in
front of other people because they're
insecure we this is not a work-life
balance conversation this is a keeping
up with the Joneses conversation maybe
if you didn't buy that home that has six
extra rooms that you never use maybe you
wouldn't have to stress at work because
maybe you know this is a far more
complex conversation then I talk about
hustle I talk about hustle here's why if
I looked at all of us right now and
everybody behind these cameras or
reading this article and said get
smarter
more talented I want you to get more
talented that's very tricky that's
unbelievably ideological advice if I
said look two extra hours of work
actually has an impact on your success
if that's what you're trying to achieve
that's practical you don't have to but
it's controllable work ethic is
controllable being born with talent is
not so a lot of my friends in Silicon
Valley who made 50 million bucks because
they had ridiculous DNA and unbelievable
platforms of entitlement and advantages
and all these other things that after
they make their 50 million bucks they
look down on everybody and say have
better work/life balance that's very
sweet but that's audacious on the flip
side the 95 percent of people who are
not happy with what's going on if they
you know if they work on their side
hustle after they work and after four
years they're selling more strawberry
jam on the internet than the money
they're making being an account
executive at grey or at Vayner and now
they're happy that makes me happy
so I think it's a much more complex
conversation than hey people meditate
for an hour a day and you'll be happy
that is band-aids why do you need to
meditate what are you up to and what are
you doing with your life and why are you
working
[Music]
first line what's up here in London
I got a facebook messenger hoodie that's
pretty [ __ ] rad and so I'm Facebook
messaging you and I'm gonna sign it
right now and then and the indie rock
are about to hide it you're about to
watch them hide it and then one of you
are gonna find it we're having fun I'm
first in line London we're having fun
and Edie rock hide it I think we have a
very weak creative conversation around
the new channels I am fascinated that
people even have this debate how many
people here have bought something on
wish the shopping app raise your hands
raise it high own it don't be scared
cool how many people here have never
heard it's cool I need the honesty here
and everyone's very [ __ ] like this
how many people here have never heard of
wish the shopping app raise your hands
this is the best moment of my life one
more time you have not heard of wish to
shopping app raise your hands high
okay this is the best thank you very
much wish depending on who you listen to
because it's a private kind of thing
company is doing anywhere between three
to six billion dollars in revenue which
is probably the closest thing to any
kind of conceivable threat to Amazon in
the world which is doing three to six
billion dollars in sales they're
spending 98% of their money outside of a
Lakers Los Angeles Lakers patch on the
Jersey and the McGregor Mayweather fight
they bought the corner outside of those
two activations they were spending 98%
of their money on Facebook ads wishes
founders are engineers from Google that
worked on the Google AdWords product
wishes doing three to six billion
dollars in sales and more than half of
this room this room not some [ __ ]
random hundred people on the street in
London this room
than half of the people don't even know
what it is that is the punchline thank
you I think why it's the punchline for
me is I have empathy to why that is we
you know one of the biggest mistakes
that people make is they make decisions
in a focus group of one I have never
made a business decision in my life
based on my own behavior that is
laughable stupid and just naive at best
and ideologically the kind of like it's
just it's not a good idea and so I'm
fascinated by how many people go into
rooms and say Gary you're right my
fourteen-year-old daughter uses
Instagram great John you know it's it's
this is not about you or your three
friends or your 17 year old niece or
like what your grandma did yesterday
this is [ __ ] data at scale this is
black and white happened this is not
happening
this is incoming 90 plus percent of the
fortune 500 CPG brands are declining in
market share in their marketing behavior
eighty percent of their spend is either
on television or programmatic digital
which is digital 2006 this is not
confusing meanwhile Jim shark and
fashion OVA and Lola and movement
watches are going from zero to 25 fifty
a hundred five hundred million dollars
in sales on 100% spend on influencer
Facebook and Instagram this is not
subjective debate like if a video is
funny this is what's happening in the
business world now just as an
observation because it's funny to say
Facebook has done an unbelievably poor
job in showcasing the people that use
the platform properly in chasing the
BMW's of McDonald's and Porsches and GES
of the world companies that blindly work
on things that have nothing to do back
to the prior presentation with actual
business but this entire industry that I
have come to love three
leads on either subjective ego opinions
or complete horseshit
metrics including in horseshit metrics
are things like data logic the way that
I sold Facebook finally to corporate
America because they finally found a
report that they liked even though the
row as on every report of data logics is
so phenomenal yet the business did not
grow data logics is Facebook's version
of Nielsen's and Millard Brown and
internal MMMs that don't take inputs
from Facebook and all the other currency
that people are trading on that has
nothing to do with the actual business
I'm fascinated by this because it is not
very difficult to do an a/b test that
does a holdout cluster that can prove to
nestlé's if their ads on Facebook versus
their ads on television or driving sales
at Tesco or Sainsbury or Walmart you can
do it if you actually cared to do it
this is a remarkably interesting time I
want to remind this very smart room that
the number one advertiser on Google
during the five to seven golden years of
it being massively under priced
attention was a company called Amazon
when you strike when you have the best
hand you win
I think that for the biggest advertisers
I have empathy for many other behaviors
but it is the analogy and needs the
context so it's not hyperbolized that
when something is grossly underpriced if
if every English LGBT analogy if every
English Premier League team reached out
to RBS Bank right now and said you know
what even though we've been getting
fifteen million dollar a year
sponsorships for our stadiums we like
you and we all want to offer you eight
year deals at 1 million a year I think
it's probably a good idea for RBS to buy
them all that's where my mind goes with
Facebook I don't think people understand
the arbitrage it's not that television
and outdoor and Direct Mail is zero or
dead not at all it's that most of those
things are overpriced this other thing
is underpriced that means it needs its
proper allocation in today's world if
you are a massive company in the UK
market between Instagram and Facebook
you are getting to a shocking amount of
people at a very low cost but meanwhile
they want to deck out a double-decker
bus for awareness you know so I would
say this nobody is allocating the
appropriate amount of money to Facebook
and Instagram given how under price that
is do I believe that Pepsi and Puma in
the UK or in Europe should spend fifty
sixty percent of their money just on
Facebook in this room the answer is yes
should they do a lot of the other things
they do yep but they should cut the
budgets on all those things so that he
can afford to 50 to 60 percent on
Facebook and Instagram I believe that
[Music]